super attenta dai andiamo in tanti e
belli che cos'è questo rumore
[Musica]
dal tavolo finale dove sei
anita sento la tua voce ma non ti vedo
[Musica]
così finalmente ma cos'è questa una
zanzara sì lo so è stata la volta
cattivo la strega è stata roma tarantino
a quello dentro la sfera di cristallo è
arrivato il cannes
tu sei sparito mi ha fatto toccare per
portare era piccola che adesso come
facciamo a fatti tornare normale non lo
so dobbiamo trovare il modo di farmi
tornare normale non posso rimanere così
per tre quattro partiti pianti dentro
nuova forma sarà ancora più difficile
cari superare le mie prove ha
conquistato una nuova forma dovrei pari
amicizia con le formiche nella tua nuova
prova di oggi dovrei trovare tutti i 12
nuovi mini daini basta e non riuscirai a
trovarli tutti e dodici rimarrai una
formica per sempre a a bordo una formina
pisani ma cosa vorrei dire guarda che
questa scatola di beni di cui stava
parlando ma è vuoto
forse li dobbiamo trovare tutte e dodici
guarda ce n'è uno qui apriamo la assieme
vediamo che cosa c'è dentro mini mini
bag tante mini sorprese che funzionano
davvero mini bag con moschettone in
metallo più 6 sorprese wow apriamolo
subito eccolo qui abbiamo degli stickers
una matita delle graffette un quadernino
in miniatura guarda che carino e infine
un nastro adesivo in miniatura e
miniature
ecco perché mi era inviso lino allora
perché s'è dovuto mare tutti vita in
miniatura che io sono rimpicciolite in
miniatura tra più difficile per me
trovarmi ma la stata cattiva conta che
noi lavoriamo in squadra facciamo così
dividiamoci tutti riusciamo a trovarlo
in più velocemente camera si dividiamoci
così magari riusciamo a trovarci prima
ma stai attenta però dopo
no no no hay ma quello che cos'è
sì l'ho tenuto l'altro giorno abbiamo
cercare gli altri dai video di berlino
che vi come ora da te c'è qualcosa ma ce
lo vedete forse uno dei militari ma
fuori passate un per viviano in grado
mondo
provatelo
mi piace entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1 a
tempo scaduto perché in visite ma sarà
mica centro 5 st gori
eccone uno per niente guardate c'è
qualcosa vicino a notare youtube di
umidità il mio approvato un altro nome
che non posso prendere adesso perché io
sono microscopica sono troppo pesanti
per me il nuovo italia quando torna di
prenderli in quattro zampino dietro al
vaso ministro mi abbiamo già trovato tre
come un altro e rosa porta merlino già
trovati due unità sarà troppo bolletta
andiamo a cercarne altri gli aiuti
merlino
che c'è di no ho trovato qualcosa da sei
bravissimo hai trovato un altro zaino
grazie bravo punirli così è stato
bravissimo è però non te li baciare
capitali da ho trovato la vita o no come
dire che lo spiaccicata con i miei piedi
dove sei la vita vita è tale ma se li
guarda ne ho trovate altri 4 giu
nei trenta l'ato4 trovano con tre minime
timi dove sono così riprendo li mettiamo
tutti insieme vediamo con se ne abbiamo
presi solo che non sono riuscito a
prendere ovviamente perché permettono ai
tantissimi ma adesso mi prendo e li
mettiamo tutti insieme eccoli qua
346 è il primo che abbiamo trovato bene
ora mi mancano solo quattro vuoi
continuare a cercare qua ho un'idea
portare fuori in giardino e io cercherò
fuori in giardino con un giardino e va
bene ma stai attenta vieni salì sulla
mia mano si sicura di voler andare da
sola in giardino potrebbe essere
pericoloso sì lo so non può essere
pericoloso per visto quel piccola e va
bene ti porto ma stai attento a
preoccupare è attenta ok allora ti
lascio qui va bene allora io ritorno a
cercare gli altri zaini se hai bisogno
di aiuto chiamami a più tardi
ciao arrivo per il gigante
[Applauso]
e cos'è questo tumore
prima di tutto per cercare gli altri
zainetti dove sono fiutando li voglio
vedere bravissimo si dice mauro masi
bravissimo dove sono gli altri cerca
martino come 16 c'è qualcosa qui ami
controllare top è qui quel mezzo da qui
c'è qualcosa guarda bravissimo ce ne
sono altri marlino dove sono c'è
qualcos'altro la dieta ha detto
bravissimo nei trovato anche un altro po
dietro sei bravissimo ed ecco qui
un'altra mini bag giu tu però
e provare a prenderlo perché avere anche
perché ancora non riesco a volare sì o
[Musica]
no è caduto ora impossibile per me ha
recuperato in realtà tutto nemmeno come
sempre da questo altro non sono che
arrivi vitale
adesso andiamo a vedere se anita trovato
qualcosa mandiamo in giardino vieni
andiamo dai andiamo vieni a vita dove
sei veramente modulo wi fi se qui ti
stavo cercando mi stavo preoccupando
cosa ci fai qua sopra
eccolo qua porta con trovato torniamo in
casa che andiamo ad aprirli abbiamo
vinto
la cosa va bene se chiarisci per
trovarli tutti basta che ben distinti
perché la prossima prova sarà molto più
difficile
[Musica]
ora che sono tornata normale possiamo
aprire tutti i mini mini bag potete
trovare i mini mini bag è in edicola in
allegato alla rivista dentro ci sono
state sorprese in miniatura a mio vedere
cosa c'é qua dentro in più c'è il
moschettone per appenderle la borsetta o
allo zaino vediamo in questo che perciò
abbiamo degli stickers poi block notes a
forma di cuore per le mini forbici che
karim e una matita è ovviamente anche se
in miniatura è tutto funzionante un mini
temperino forma di cuore che carino è
una minigonna
apriamo adesso questo blu e scriveteci
nei commenti qual è il vostro preferito
vediamo qual caso troviamo abbiamo altre
visivi diverse di quaderni azzurro
matita mini evidenziatore profumato alla
banana minigonna e mini temperino forma
di cuore
apriamo ora questo oro slitterà presto
penna segreta vediamo mini forbice
minigonna graffette mini per berlino che
carino e gli adesivi zaino verde che
calano nozze a forma di fiore mini
righello gli adesivi matita e lo scotch
e dorato glitterato che li detentivi
vediamo in questo krazia cosa c'è
adesivi
una mini pensatrice che carina ci sono
anche le ricariche da mette andiamo a
provarla graffette colorate matita e
minigo ma qual è la vostra mini mini bag
preferite la vostra sorpresa preferite a
scrivetelo nei commenti vi ricordo
potete trovarli in edicola in allegato
al magazine mio preferito questo rosa
brillante il tuo il mio quello blu
invece lascia un ben misero in questo
video è ora vi lasciamo quando sulla
linea su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video kat su quella che
preferite